if you
he is risen.
Okay, he is risen.
amen, amen
They always talk about how Easter Sunday
is fairly simple to preach because
there's already a lot of anticipation and a lot of things going
in life. It's one of my favorite Sundays of
the year. It really does feel like there is newness. There's
life there's excitement. And so I pray that that's true
for you today that there may be some Resurrection happening in your own
heart as you are here, but the
last couple weeks we have been talking about
how this this gospel message
these first four books of the New Testament. We
call the gospels how that points us to believing
in Jesus as the Son of God and
talking specifically in that defense that
you may believe and we've said that each gospel writer Matthew
Mark Luke and John they were they were inspired by
God's spirit to record not just by a graphical information
about Jesus but to talk about how the
gospel message his life death and Resurrection
is the Hope for sinners like
and me
it's not just a hey there's Sue. Jesus was like here's what he
did for us as well. That's what the
whole gospels are about and that's the really the thread
that runs through all four of the gospels that
is diverse. As you read them to be
they all have the same basic skeleton of events that point
us to this good news.
If you remember over the last couple weeks if you've been here that truth
is that Jesus has existed from eternity
past.
Yet he took on flesh was born of a virgin.
He lived a perfect life revealing the
father through his his truth speaking
and through his power revealing his
his miraculous work that he was doing
he showed who God was to us yet, even
though he never sinned in that whole process of
his life. He was brutally nailed to
a tree for
our sin
what we deserved
that he became a sacrifice in our place to
pay the price for our sin and open the way back
up to God.
Yet as we've already said today his death was not
the end.
There was hope coming that that after a couple days he
walked out of that tomb alive where he
then defeated sin and death forever in that
action.
See that is the cohesive thread that
runs through all four of the gospels. They all have a
different perspective on those events. But but
that's what holds it all together really holds
the whole Bible together when you look at it in its essence.
But Matthew wrote that to the
Jews Luke wrote that to the Gentiles and
we'll see today.
How John has perspective on
those events and and his unique Viewpoint as
he walks through that with Jesus?
So if you're not already there, let's take our copies of
God's word together and turn with me to The Gospel
according to John.
If you don't have one there might be a hardback one around
you underneath one of the seats. If you don't have a Bible take that
with you, that's our gift to you. We'd love for you to take that and read
about who Jesus is.
But we're gonna be in The Gospel according to John chapter 20 nearly
towards the end of John.
And the end of chapter 20 as well.
John chapter 20 starting verse 30 is where we're going to be now.
Here's one tip about how to read the Bible.
Like when you're reading through the Bible if you're unfamiliar with
how to do that one tip is just to look for a purpose statement
in each book.
Why did that person write what they wrote and
so thankfully in the Book of John The Gospel according to
John we have his he gave us his purpose statement
here. It is John chapter 20 verse 30 and
31.
Now Jesus did many other signs in the presence of the
disciples which are not written in this book.
But these the things that I write down
are written.
So that you may believe that Jesus
is the Christ the son of God.
And that by believing you may have
life in his name.
So again out of the millions of things that
John could have included here about Jesus. Did you
see why the Holy Spirit inspired John to
write the things that he did.
So that you would believe.
So that I would believe.
That Jesus is the Christ the son of
God the savior.
And that that belief he says would lead to
life in his name.
That's why we do this every week.
That's why we gather like this. That's why we talk about Jesus the
way we do that's why we've defended why we
can trust what we have in the Bible. It's so that we
can challenge you challenge each other
with the truth of this good news. That's the power
of God for the Salvation of those who believe.
It's merely to put Jesus in front of us and what he's
done so that we would believe.
That's why some of you are here today.
We pray.
But listen, even if you hear all that and you're like, okay, I
already believe all this already. Okay, even if you believe
all this already, aren't you looking for life?
Like that's what John says right so they may have life in
his name. Aren't you looking for life and couragement? That's what
we live our lives for. We're always looking for better.
John says it's found here.
In what I've written and so so as
you hear all this don't check out don't think this is just evangelism don't
think this is not for you. This is for you as
well to find life.
In what John's written here?
So here's the first unique element that John included is
he looked at jesus' life and gospel from
his perspective.
Here's the first unique thing that John included here in verses
19 through 29 of chapter 20, just right
above where we read a second ago.
Now the context here, let me set the scene was this
was after Jesus had come back to life. He died
on the cross been buried resurrected from the grave
were in that time. He spent a couple weeks with his
disciples where he was teaching them training them challenging them.
This is in that time frame. In
fact, this is the first time he shows up to the
majority of the disciples at one time.
Look at verse 19.
On the evening of that day the first day of the week the doors being
locked where the disciples were for fear of the Jews.
Jesus came and stood among them and
said to them peace be with you.
And when he had said this he showed them his hands
and his side.
Then the disciples were glad when they saw the Lord and
Jesus said to them again. Peace be
with you.
As the father has sent me even so I am
sending you.
By the way, this is where we get. Our our churches intentional Expressions
live sent you are
sent you hear us say that all the time it's in our mission statement.
This is from this phrase. It's by
extension from the disciples to us Matthew 28 can tie
it together to where Jesus sent his disciples. So
then we also have been sent by Jesus.
But notice what just happened here.
We saw it last week. If you were here. We were walking through the Book of Mark
and and what we saw there was all the
disciples had abandoned Jesus in the garden the night
before he was crucified at his arrest they ran
away, but here just a couple days later. They're still
scared.
Right there. They're hiding in this room locking the door.
Let's get him a little Grace though here.
Because think about it their leader had just been killed.
They didn't know he'd been resurrected yet.
Their leader was dead. The whole religious establishment was
after them like they were a part of this
Insurrection. And so
They're scared. But do you see do you
see the grace of Jesus here?
the grace of Jesus in just showing up
the grace of Jesus to to prove
to them his resurrection because if
you read through the rest of the New Testament, you know that this whole
thing we're doing here it rises and falls on whether
Jesus is alive or not.
That's why Easter matters so much that this thing would fall
apart if Jesus had stayed in the Tomb. It's
really pointless for us to do what we're doing here if he stayed in the
Tomb, that's why it shows his grace.
To them to just show up.
But as he did this notice he did he said something
twice.
He said peace be with you.
And why did he say it two times?
first of all
Because these men were in a room and the doors
were locked and all of a sudden Jesus just appeared.
Like we don't know if he teleported in walk through the wall.
We don't know right and so that would be terrifying if a man
just shows up in the room with you and so they needed.
Peace.
Peace be with you. Don't be scared.
But also because of the context remember what I just described earlier.
Like we see the grace of Jesus showing up to these when
life was in chaos.
Their Futures uncertain at this point. They don't know
what's going to happen next. And so Jesus says, I'm
going to give you my peace.
And notice he didn't do that by changing their circumstances.
He gave them his Peace by giving himself.
He shows up and says peace be with you.
That's what he said back in John 14:27. He said Peace I leave
with you my peace. I give to you not as
the world gives do I give it to you? Let not your
hearts be troubled neither. Let them be afraid.
He gives peace in a different way that we think peace is like no war
no fighting. He says no pieces me.
Me with you.
Okay, so you're thinking that's great and all but but these
guys.
They were just seeing things, right?
I mean, they desperately wanted Jesus to be alive and so their mind
was playing tricks with them and they saw him right? They they thought they
saw him at least.
No, Jesus was really with them
because that's what he did when he allowed them
to see the wounds in his wrists and the the
big wound in his side where the spear went in. They they
saw it.
And that's why it led to great joy to
gladness in their hearts. Why because
they knew it was really him.
That he's alive and like
this is good news for them right there. They are terrified and
now their leaders alive again what great news
that is
now I know.
That's some of you may struggle to believe that that really happened.
That Jesus really has been resurrected from the grave because that doesn't make
any sense in your brain that somebody's dead and then they can just come back to life.
That doesn't happen.
Well, you're not alone in that doubt.
Look down at verse 24.
Now Thomas, this is a little bit later after that scene Thomas. One
of the twelve called the twin another name
for him was not with them. When Jesus came
that first time in the the locked room Thomas wasn't
there and so the other disciples told him Hey
Thomas, we've seen the Lord.
But Thomas said to them unless I see
in his hands the mark of the nails placed my finger
into the mark of the nails.
And place my hand into his side. I will
never believe.
Now we tend to give old doubting Thomas here a lot of grief.
But just a few days or hours even earlier don't you
recognize that the disciples themselves needed the
confirmation to?
Right this that they thought it might have been some kind
of ghost or appearance of some sort and until they
saw his hands and his side. They didn't believe that's
when they had to gladness.
So Thomas here just needed another step
of assurance. It wasn't any different than
the original disciples needed. He just he wanted to actually
touch the scars and and feel those
things that Jesus really was real.
Well, look at how round two plays out.
Seeing God's grace.
again
Look at verse 26.
eight days later
His disciples were inside again. So we don't know if
they're locked if it's hiding again, but at least they were inside a
room and Thomas was with them this time, although the doors
were locked. So there it is. They were locked. They're still scared. Jesus
came and stood among them.
And said peace be with you now
again, he just shows up out of
nowhere. So they're terrified. Peace be with you again. So
there it is.
But you can imagine in this scene.
Jesus turning as he appears turning
to a stunned and Silent Thomas.
And walking over.
to Thomas
watch verse 27
and then he said to Thomas.
Put your finger here. See my hands.
Put out your hand place it in my side.
Do not disbelieve but believe.
What Grace right?
Jesus showed up and and met Thomas where
he was.
Thomas even in his doubts in
his concerns in his questions Jesus
showed up and met Thomas right in the middle of those. He
said Hey Thomas look even even touch this
Thomas she feel free to touch this.
now we don't know if Thomas actually did follow through
with touching his hands and his side but doesn't say
But Watch What Happens verse 28?
Thomas answered him
my Lord and my God.
One of the greatest Declarations of truth from anyone's
mouth and all of God's word.
my Lord
meeting my authority my owner the one
in charge of my life.
And my God, he says my my God a phrase
reserved for Yahweh in the Jews minds
and so is as Thomas says that he
equates Jesus with the father with Yahweh.
My Lord and my God.
Now again, I know you might be sitting there wavering and
wondering whether you can believe this.
And and you're looking at this and you're saying oh, of course Thomas believed.
I mean he could literally touch Jesus. He saw him
face to face. Of course Thomas believed. How can I believe
Well, Jesus spoke directly to
you.
in the next verse
verse 29 look at this
Jesus said to Thomas have you believed because you have seen
me.
Blessed are those who have
not seen?
And yet have believed.
He was talking to you friend.
He was talking to you.
He's calling you and me to believe as
well.
He's calling you and me to believe even though that we have not seen him
face to face, even though he never promises to
show up in your room physically when you ask him to.
Even though he's not walking around on the earth on in physical
form anymore today. We still Must Believe
In The Resurrection.
We still must believe this and remember when we say belief we're
talking about mentally agreeing to the facts of
the Resurrection. Yes, but also even
more staking your whole future on it.
It's turning from all your sin and your stuff and
yourself that keeps you from Jesus.
And it's turning to him as
Lord in faith that he has done enough
for your eternity.
That's belief.
That's how you are saved from the penalty of
your sin.
Romans 10:9 says that if you confess with
your mouth that Jesus is Lord.
And believe in your heart that God raised him from the
dead you will be saved.
That's how you are saved and
so believe friend.
Like Thomas did confess Jesus as the Lord
of your life as your God believe that
you are a sinner in need of a Salvation that
you can never offer yourself that you can never provide yourself.
confess and believe
because when you do
when you do turn from yourself and turn it
to your savior, here's what you receive you receive his
forgiveness.
When you believe in him?
You receive his forgiveness. Remember we're looking at aspects
unique to John and there's a incredibly powerful
picture of this.
It's in the next chapter chapter 21.
Which is a post-resurrection scene it's after again
the resurrection, but it's exclusive to John.
Where the disciples had kind of gone back to their previous lives?
They were unsure what to do next because they they hadn't
been instructed what to do. And so they were just sort of living their lives
and walking through it all and many of them were fishermen.
So they go kind of back to that and one of them one night
they were out fishing and they were catching
nothing.
And a stranger stood on the shore and he yelled at
them to put their Nets on the other side of the boat and see what happens. And
so they're like, okay we do and they catch loads of
fish 153 actually exactly.
And they quickly figure out that that's Jesus over there. And so they
hurry over to the shore.
Jesus was already cooking them breakfast on the shore.
but I want you to remember something here just
Just days earlier.
These same men had abandoned Jesus
in the garden.
They'd run away at the first sign of
trouble. They left him on his own peter even later
denied that he even knew Jesus
three separate times.
Well after they ate on the shore together it was
time for a conversation.
This is John chapter 21 starting down in verse 15.
When they had finished breakfast, Jesus said to Simon
Peter Simon, son of John. Do you love me more
than these?
And Peter said to Jesus. Yes, Lord. You know that. I
love you.
He said to him feed my Lambs.
He said to him a second time Simon son of John do you
love me?
He said to him. Yes, Lord. You know that. I love you.
Jesus said to Peter 10 my sheep.
He said to him the third time Simon son
of John do you love me?
And Peter was grieved because he said to him
the third time do you love me?
And Peter said to him Lord, you know
everything.
You know that I love you.
And Jesus said to him feed my sheep.
So not once not twice, but three
times. Jesus asked Peter the
question. Do you love me?
And not once not twice, but three times Peter responded.
Of course. I love you Jesus.
Now, why did Jesus ask Peter three times?
Bible doesn't say explicitly here, but think about
it.
Remember how many times Peter denied Jesus?
three times
I think this moment was Jesus redeeming and
restoring and forgiving Peter.
Because notice first Jesus reconfirmed the relationship here.
Because implied in jesus' question
of Peter. Hey, Peter. Do you love me is the
Priceless reassurance because I
still love you Peter.
By Jesus wouldn't ask that question. If he didn't
love Peter first down notice Jesus didn't chastise
Peter. He didn't rehash what happened.
He didn't give Peter the cold shoulder, but
he also didn't blow it off as no big deal.
No, Jesus affirmed his love
for Peter and he gave Peter the opportunity to
affirm his love back.
to say to Jesus Lord
like Thomas just did.
But listen, this is what Jesus Does.
For any who come to him in faith?
This scene no matter what you've done no matter how far
you've gone. Jesus comes after
you.
Jesus does what he does, he paid
the price to forgive you and praise God
he did that because there's no other way out of it for us
in our sin.
forgives
but listen, here's what I often happens at this point.
See for most of you. That's not new information.
None of what I've said is new like if you've been an Easter Service
before, you know that Jesus died and Jesus rose again.
You know that Jesus forgives sin, you know
that Jesus is the savior.
But do you know why?
Do you know why he saves?
Why he forgives?
Why he redeems?
Is it just to give us Heaven someday?
Is it just for us to kind of lazily sit around here and
wait for him to return and take us to Heaven? Is that is
that why he saves us?
Mr. Sounds like we talked about that a lot that way.
Which will get a cushy life because of this and cushy eternities
that why he saves no.
Did you notice what else Jesus did with Peter
here in John 21?
Not only did he Recon the relationship.
He also reconfirmed Peter's purpose.
because after each affirmation of Love Came a
form of this command from Jesus
feed my sheep.
Now this is not new information to Peter because
even just a few chapters earlier at the
the scene where they were having the Passover meal
together Jesus even predicted Peter's
denials.
Yet he also added this.
Hey Peter, when you have turned again strengthen
your brothers.
See Jesus knew Peter would
fall.
But Jesus also knew that Peter would repent
and Peter would recommit his life to the
mission of God.
Again, this is what Jesus Does.
These same guys who last week ran away
in fear. They were hiding. He then restored
them and redeemed them
through his death and Resurrection for their
sin.
He knew they were all going to run.
And he still went to the Cross. He still resurrected to
overcome their sin and your sin as
well. Listen, it's the same for you and me today.
We run from God.
Yes, Jesus restores by faith.
But hear me again, Jesus did all of that.
Not for us to just live cushy lives.
and to be decent American citizens
and to sit here every week and listen to Somebody talk for
45 minutes up here. That's not the whole point
of this thing.
He did all of that so that we
would be committed to his mission committed to
his purpose committed to him Above All Else. He
loved us and saved us so that we would pursue
his kingdom now.
That's that's what he does. He gives forgiveness so that
we would pursue his kingdom so that we would seek
first the kingdom of God and
his righteousness.
So Jesus said back in Matthew 6:33, that's what he
wants for us to do and I know that's daunting
you think about your life like okay seeking first the king in
everything I have to do this, but that's part of what I skipped
it a little bit earlier in John chapter 20 verse 22 where
Jesus plants his spirit in
his followers so that they can live
out what he's calling them to live out.
It's the power source to be able to do this.
So there's that we can't forget, but I also want you to see something here.
It's really important. Did you see that Peter was to
follow this purpose?
Feed my sheep this purpose of God this mission of
God. He was to do that not out of
obligation.
But out of love for Jesus.
Peter do you love me?
If you love me feed my sheep.
If you love me follow me, if you love
me. Obey me it's the same for us.
See because he first loved us.
We are to love him with everything. We are
we are to give our lives for what he wants
for what his design and his plan
is in the world.
We are then to live for something bigger than ourselves
bigger than just a little bit better life here
or bigger than getting our own selfish way and how
we want our lives to be on this Earth. No, it's
something so much bigger. It's what Jesus himself said
back in John chapter
18.
So take just a quick glance over there
back to the left a little bit of scroll up a little bit John chapter 18.
We'll show you this.
John 18 starting in verse 33
Again, this is another scene unique to John.
John 18:33, this was Jesus back before
he was crucified. He's dialoguing with the Roman leader
pilot that he's talking about how he's been
accused of insurrection.
But look at how he responds to Pilate.
John 18 starting in verse 33 so
pilot entered his headquarters again and called Jesus and
said to him. Are you the king of the
Jews?
And Jesus answered kind of getting to Pilots heart. Do you
say this of your own accord or did others
say it to you about me?
Pilot answered it. Well, am I a Jew your own nation
and the chief priests have delivered you over to me. What have
you done?
And Jesus answered my kingdom is not of
this world.
If my kingdom were of this world, my servants would
have been fighting.
That I might not be delivered over to the Jews,
but my kingdom is not from the
world.
Now what pilot was doing was trying to figure out if he should be worried about
a political rival here.
Because Rome is going to squash that really fast.
But Jesus was saying that his kingdom.
Is infinitely higher than Rome's Kingdom.
That there's no political rival here because Rome gets
squashed compared to the
kingdom of God, but what did Jesus mean here? What is
this Kingdom? He's talking about this other worldly Kingdom.
Well,
it's everywhere that Jesus rules and Reigns as
Lord.
Now one day fully and finally on Earth that will
happen.
But until that day comes it's in
the hearts and lives of believers.
That's why Jesus can say in John 17 that his followers are
not of the world.
We're of a different Kingdom and it's why the Colossians
1 verses 13 and 14 says this here's
the reason because he has delivered us from the
domain of darkness and transferred us
to the kingdom of his beloved Son
in whom we have Redemption the Forgiveness of sins.
Like that means that we are citizens of a new
kingdom if we believe.
Now we still live here. We still have bodies are still National boundaries and
borders on Earth. Yes, but Jesus wasn't talking
about a location here.
He's talking about how the authority and
power of his kingdom are derived from a source
outside of this world.
It's not from the battle. That's why he says my followers would
have been fighting but this is not where my Kingdom lives.
It's not a national geopolitical entity. This
is something that is an eternal
Authority that I am the Sovereign God is what he's saying
over all things and so
My kingdom is not just here.
Here's what that means.
If we are members of his
kingdom by faith.
If we are followers of Jesus.
Then his authority supersedes all other authority on
this Earth.
My kingdom is not of this world. This
world then means for us that this is
not our home.
And we owe our allegiance to our true home to
our ultimate authority to King Jesus
himself.
That that's our Authority that means here this our value
systems should be different than the worlds. Our
Behavior should be different our response
to fools online should be different.
Are use of money should be different.
Our love for our enemies should be different our faithfulness in
marriage should be different. Our parenting should be
different our lives today because we're
citizens of a new kingdom should be a foretaste of
what is coming one day fully and finally on Earth.
When Jesus the king descends after he ascended
we'll talk about that next week, but the descending of Jesus back
to Earth to reign as king over all things, that's
fully and finally we get a we get to be a foretaste
of that a practice session of what's coming
someday.
Again, why?
Because we serve a Risen Savior King named Jesus.
That our King cannot be defeated because he defeated
sin on the cross. He defeated death in
his resurrection. And he's one day coming back to Reign Over
All Things fully and finally, he's a
savior King who gives us the opportunity to join
in his Kingdom Purpose is even today.
How stunning is that?
And we get to live out the kingdom principles.
And so friend listen carefully.
the question on the table is this
Who do you say that? Jesus is?
Whether you've never been to church ever in your life, or maybe you've
been in church your entire life.
What is your declaration about who Jesus is?
number Peter
said to Jesus Lord, you know everything.
remember Thomas
my Lord and my God.
But do you remember what Pilate?
Said to Jesus in John 18.
Pilate asked Jesus. Are you the king of the Jews remember what
Jesus said?
And it's the same question. He's asking you today.
Pilot, is that what you believe?
Or is that what everybody else has told you?
is that
Just what you've grown up hearing about.
Or is that what you really believe?
Is that just because you're in the atmosphere of church
world?
Or is that really who you say Jesus is?
Is that what you believe or is that just what you've heard
from others?
See today, we are inviting you to meet
not just an absent disinterested God.
We're not even inviting you to meet just a good guy who
sacrificed for other people because when
you hear those things you can refuse that very easily
and doesn't really change anything in your life. No, we're inviting you
today to meet the reigning King of Kings.
We're inviting you to meet a savior who forgives
you through his blood and who designed
you to worship and to live fully for
him.
Anything else you and I pursue in
our lives will leave us unsatisfied. We'll leave
us unfulfilled. He designed it a certain
way and so hear me believe in him today.
Repent and believe turn from your
sin yourself and turn to him if maybe for the first time that would
be great turn from your sin and yourself and turn
to this Jesus in faith and trust John 1:12. He
starts in chapter one by saying all who received him
who believed in his name. He gave the right
to become children of God.
What a blessing.
To be in the family of God.
It's through belief.
But also listen for every single one of us.
See more of who this Savior King really is.
Don't just let Easter pass by a death Resurrection.
Okay, we got all that stuff. This is who he is and take
a step of faith today.
To pursue his great Kingdom because
of his great love for you.